everyone knows you as number 24 which
happens to be my lucky number so
whatever but I know you as the guy who
took Brandi to prom I mean how did that
happen that's amazing I just saw her she
was like well we show back she was
yes she's noise yeah no just a high
school kid but I needed a date so my
gosh you showed up to Brahma mawisha
yeah yeah damn I didn't have here by
choice back there that's all right it's
working it's working let's go back even
further though tell us about this like
the running man was the real running man
it was like this little running man yeah
no and yeah I was energetic I was
passionate what was that school is that
like a school talent show yeah it was a
school talent show in Italy and my
sister was a part of it it's an act
dropped out and so she asked me if I
would do it and big sister kind of was
like hey listen you're doing it and so I
did it
Oh see all I like clothes yeah so so I
did that that show what do you think my
children will be close when do you think
that's gonna happen you know we got four
and they're all like yeah well you know
how I did it like it just happens and
then as they get older I think they get
a little closer it hasn't quite happened
for us yeah me neither but no but
they're like they're close but they're
not yeah then what they love each other
but yeah sorry the Thrones which one are
they which one's gonna be the ultimate
he's gonna sit on the Iron Throne
yeah sixteen we got sixteen thirteen too
soon to be three and one that just
turned four months whoa yeah tired for
months listen yeah she's like finally
you're home you get a chance to do
something versus like wait but yours are
all girls all girls it's a lot of
estrogen
like like you went from hanging out with
all dudes to like just rocking with
women
pretty much yeah that's a lot all right
I just leave the remote where it is I'll
lay my 591 I'm not fighting that
battling I'm not all we watch is
animated stuff so yeah yeah yeah so you
probably watch a lot of like [ __ ] oh
dude I saw you singing Malone on carpool
care I was singing along with you dude
you guys well how did I do you did some
sweets you can to see like a grown man
like my husband sings to my children I
mean you kind of have to know like if
you're changing them I want to change
the table and you see them start kind of
go turn from black mamba to the white
Mamba okay when you're coaching your
daughter's team which i think is amazing
that you do that like do people are you
are you black mamba are you dad
what combination of both okay cuz you
are a Virgo so I know you got to be a
little controlling about perfection but
but what I found is really fun to teach
all the girls like they're very
passionate about the game they're very
curious about the game so I try to teach
them like the finite details of the game
for example we do think sometimes in by
the way this is my little Taurus right
here oh yeah it's real sweet now until
oh she's a little aggressive that we are
Tauruses are a little bit yep this is
the future yeah my wife's a Taurus too
and so oh my gosh she's guys do that
she's awesome
I love being a choice I did ask my nanny
though and my assistant because I don't
know all things sports ball but my nanny
and assistant are crazy when it comes to
sports they know more than any man
around me it's crazy so sports ball fans
everywhere want to know there are a lot
of high-profile duo's this year besides
LeBron and Anthony Davis who are you
most excited to see play together okay
do
stick out or something on this is like
dynamic duo's what two people do you
think stand out though
what's once you expend about so there's
another duo in LA
quite Leonard and Paul George that are
really tough yeah really really tough
and then there's one in Houston James
Harden Russell Westbrook I'm going to
all like that's all like finale if you
watch them play I mean they're they're
all insane yeah that's what I don't get
into sports when I'm at a game I really
enjoy I don't like watching it on TV I
like being there you know what I kind of
know like watch it on TV yeah so much
stuff I could be doing my house like
yeah I'm like if I'm at the game you
would think I am a die-hard I'm like I
have no idea what's happening you go at
home and you're like yeah I would much
rather do anything else so tell me about
you're an author so tell me about your
new book yes we have a book coming out
called epic on a tree of eat kroff
mmm-hmm and it's a it's about a young
girl and a young boy who grew up on
opposite sides of the spectrum one's a
princess
other one grows up in the streets and
they go to a very prestigious sports
academy and and at that sports academy
have some evil crap happen and they
gotta figure out how to save the day so
even though it's a sports book it's
really not much to do with sport and it
says that sport is just a metaphor for
life so when you feel anxiety when you
feel nervousness when you have to learn
how to communicate better with others we
have a way of manifesting that magically
into the sport itself so kids have a
visual of how to learn about emotional
intelligence and how to develop that
through the journey of the characters so
that's what we try to do I love it it's
deep like our kids keep getting content
that's like very superficial yeah you
know and I also don't want to have
stories out there that teach my
daughters like it's okay to have
ambition and the thing that always
drives me crazy is that every story with
a female protagonist feels like you need
to have like a romantic counterpart in a
way we don't need that
no no no like
she loves tennis yeah she loves track
she loves basketball that's it you know
so maybe that's just the father so you
don't have enough jobs okay you also
have a podcast for your so awesome I
thought I had a lot of things going on
I've met my match tell us about the
podcast for kids it's a fun podcast
called the pew knees and I was inspired
by if you guys have ever seen a movie to
say a lot yes so like saying what's a
classy we watch it every 4th of July as
a family we sit around with burgers hot
dogs anyone watch the Sandlot and one
year I was watching I was like man we
need something like that in you and so
that's when I created a podcast show
called the pew knees which is just just
about a bunch of neighborhood kids that
play sports together and learn from each
other yeah like very valuable lessons
through sports
we don't have coaches in the podcast or
our parents in the podcast it's
literally the kids ribbing each other
and joking with you like it's a law that
is so clever I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this